James, can I get some Thank You Note writing music, please?
♪♪
-Wow.
-Thank you, "The Watcher," for showing me
what it would look like if Michael Myers was into Zillow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, couples costumes, for being the cutest way
to tell the world you had an argument.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Wear it."
♪♪
-Thank you, giant skeletons, for making it look like
my neighbors are really into Halloween
or really not into Shaq.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
♪♪
-Thank you, adult twins, for kind of being a scary costume
any day of the year.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ] Thank you,
dogs willing to wear Halloween costumes,
for looking at their owners and going,
"Sure. I'll do it. It seems like they need this."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What more can I give?"
-"Live it up."
♪♪
-Thank you, houses that give out full-sized candy bars,
for letting me know which families on the block
are doing pretty, pretty good this year.
There you have it, everybody. Those are my Thank You Notes.